the moment the queen's heart stops
beating charles becomes king he is
proclaimed king by the accession council
that happened as we saw within 24 hours
of the queen's death but he may not be
crowned for several months i'm hearing
from my sources that it's likely to be
in the spring if king charles passes
before queen consort camilla because of
the order of succession the crown
automatically passes to his heir
apparent
the prince of wales prince william so
camilla would not keep her title as
queen consort she would lose that title
and that title would move to kate i was
told by sources very close to the king
that he was determined that when his
time came and he sat on the throne he
would absolutely have queen camilla as
you will know we are all referring to
her at the moment as queen consort
camilla that is going to be the title
bestowed on her when the king is titled
king in that final funeral ceremony it's
in george's chapel what happens further
on down the line we'll have to wait and
see we know that the issue of titles
matters enormously to the prince of
wales there was speculation that he
didn't want the title of the duke of
edinburgh for example to pass to his
younger brother prince edward we're told
by the palace that the issue of titles
is going to be something that is going
to be sorted out after the official
mourning period and don't forget the
royals have a further seven full days of
mourning after the funeral on monday so
what of the titles for archie and lilly
beck which has caused i think it's fair
to say a storm of controversy well
by law now that charles is king
any sons of the sovereign are entitled
to take the prince title the hrh title
and their children are entitled to take
the hrh title it is why prince andrew's
daughters beatrice and eugenie are their
royal highnesses princess beatrice of
york and princess eugenie of york now
eagle-eyed royal watchers will have
noted that on the official royal website
archie and lily bert are not prince and
princess arch in lily but yet they are
still mr and miss
archie and lilybert i think the reason
that they are master archie and miss
lillybet still is because a formal
decision hasn't been taken yet as to the
announcement of those titles are there
going to be hrh it's unlikely given that
that is what harry and megan have
dropped but i believe that it's the case
that they will be prince and princess
and i think a lot rides on these titles
are we going to see this eagerly
anticipated autobiography of harry's are
there going to be more interviews
essentially trashing the royal family i
think titles are given to those who have
earned them and i think at the moment
the jury might still be out is there any
chance that harry and megan might be
given their hrh titles back well of
course after mexi after they made the
announcement that they were standing
down as senior members of the royal
family that they were no longer
representing the then queen they were
stripped of those honorary titles now
the queen made it very clear that the
door was always left open for megan and
harry to return if they wanted to and i
believe that it is actually king
charles's hope that they might well be
able to come back into the royal fold in
some sort of a capacity it wouldn't be
impossible to give back those hrh titles
but it would take an absolute 360 turn
on megan and harry's part to give up all
of the commercial work and to come back
as fully fledged members of the firm and
i think there's probably too much water
under the bridge for that to happen
[Music]
you